[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وافق النواب
العراقيون على تعيين وزيرين جديدين للدفاع
والداخليه ليكتمل بذلك تشكيل الحكومه
العراقيه برئاسه حيدر العبادي والتي تقاتل
ضد تمدد تنظيم الدوله على الاراضي
العراقيه نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين هل قدم التشكيل المكتمل للحكومه
العراقيه جديدا ام انه اعاده انتاج لحكومه
سابقه تسببت في اقصاء المكون
السني والى اي مدى يمكن ان تنجح هذه
الحكومه في حرب تنظيم الدوله بينما تتواصل
ممارسات حكوميه ضد مكون
بعينه
اخيرا اكتمل تشكيل حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
العراقيه بعد موافقه البرلمان على تعيين
وزير الداخليه والدفاع وزاره الداخليه
تولاها محمد الغبان وهو عضو في منظمه بدر
الشيعيه اما وزاره الدفاع فتولاها خالد
العبيدي وهو سياسي سني هذه الخطوه راها
البعض اساسيه في مواجهه تنظيم الدوله لكن
اخرين طرحوا تساؤلات عن مدى قدره هذه
الحكومه على ارضاء السنه الذين عانوا من
اقصاء في ظل حكومه
سابقه ما الذي تغير حتى يوصف تعيين وزيرين
للدفاع والداخليه في العراق بانه
انجاز يذهب المالكي فيؤتى بالعباد من
الصندوق نفسه يشكل الرجل حكومه جديده
فيختلف حول منصبي الداخليه والدفاع فيها
كان المرشح للداخليه قائد منظمه بدر
الشيعيه هادي العامري فرفضه ساسه سنه فتم
اللجوء ثانيه الى الصندوق نفسه ومن صندوق
منظمه بدر هذه المره جيء بمحمد الغبان
وزيرا للداخليه اما السني خالد العبيدي
فجيء به للدفاع وتلك اقل اهميه في العراق
من الداخليه كون رئيس الوزراء قائدا اعلى
للقوات المسلحه الرجل من مدينه الموصل
التي سقطت ثمره الناضجه في ايد تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه في حزيران الماضي وهو
فيما تذكر مصادر عده كان في المدينه انذاك
لكنه غادرها قبل ساعات قليله فقط من
سقوطها لم يدافع عن مدينته لكنه وجد نفسه
لاحقا وزيرا للدفاع عن البلاد باسرها تلك
تجليات المحاصصه الطائفيه التي تحكم
البلاد منذ الاطاحه بصدام حسين فيها يتقدم
الشيعه الى المناصب الاكثر اهميه وحساسيه
بينما تذهب المناصب الاخرى للمكون الكردي
والسني ومنذ صعود تنظيم الدوله وجد
الاكراد انفسهم في وضع من يملي الشروط على
الحكومه في بغداد الى جانبهم تصطف دول
غربيه وجدت في اربيل نقطه ارتكاز لمحاربه
تنظيم الدوله ورجالهم يقاتلون جنبا الى
جنب مع قوات التحالف وهنا بريطانيون
يدربونهم ويسل الحونه فاذا هم عنصر حاسم
في اقرار مصير العراق اما المكون الشيعي
المهيمن على الدوله فانه سرعان ما ينكفئ
الى طفيته عندما يستشعر الخطر وتتراجع
المؤسسه لصالح الحوزه الجيش لصالح
الميليشيات وبتقدم مسلحي تنظيم الدوله نحو
بغداد سرعان ما قامت مجموعات منهم لا من
الجيش بالانتشار على حدود المدينه ياتي
هذا وقوات التحالف تقصف من الجو اهدافا
للتنظيم بدلا من الجيش العراقي بل وتقوم
بانزال الامدادات الغذائيه لهم من الجو
ليتفرغوا للقتال وحدها مناطق المكون السني
تحرق حرقا كما توضح هذه الصور فلا تسعف
بدواء ولا غذاء ولا يتطوع من يدافع عنها
والحال هذه يزدهر تنظيم الدوله هناك ويمتد
ويشتد
عودا موضوع حلقتنا هذه نناقشه مع ضيوفنا
يحيى الكبيسي مستشار المركز العراقي
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه من عمان ومن بيروت
عباس الموسوي مدير المركز الاعلامي
العراقي في بيروت ومن واشنطن مع بيجي
كراولي المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه سابقا مرح مرحبا بضيوفي الكرام
استاذ يح الكبيسي هل باكتمال تشكيله حكومه
العبادي تكون الازمه السياسيه في العراق
قد انتهت ما حجم الامال التي يعلقها
المكون السني على هذه الحكومه
ايضا يعني بدايه مساء الخير لك ولضيفك
الكريمين ولجمهور الكريم لا انا اعتقد
يعني الازمه في العراق اعمق من قضيه تشكيل
الحكومه كنا نقول منذ البدايه انه الازمه
في العراق هي ازمه النظام السياسي وليست
ازمه شخوص يعني لم تكن الازمه مع شخص
السيد المالكي وانما مع النظام السياسي
التي انتجت ظاهره المالكي بمعنى تغول
السلطه التنفيذيه بالشكل الذي يعني مع
الذي حصل مع سياسات المالكي الان ليس هناك
يعني اي مؤشرات على وجود تغيير حقيقي نعم
يعني ازاحه المالكي انا اعتقد كانت خطوه
مهمه لكن لحد الان لم نلمس مؤشرات على
الارض نحن امام خطابات يعني البرنامج
السياسي الذي طرحه الدكتور حيدر العبادي
كان يعني برنامجا يحاول ان يلامس بعض
المشكلات ولكنه لا يلامس ازمه الجوهريه في
العراق اللي هي ازمه النظام السياسي ولكن
اليس هذا حكم استذ يجب ان تعالج ن اليس
هذا حكم مسبق ب ل على اعتبار ان الحكومه
لم تبدا عملها بعد وباعتبار ايضا ان هناك
ظرف امني يعني استثنائي في
البلاد لا لا عندما اتحدث انا هنا سانق
وثيقتين الوثيقتين الرئيسيتين للحكومه هي
البرنامج الحكومي وما سمي بوثيقه الكتل
السياسيه من يقرا ه هاتين الوثيقتين
سيكتشف انه ليست هناك معالجات حقيقيه لجذر
الازمه وانما هناك معالجات لنتائج الازمه
هذه هي المشكله الرئيسيه بمعنى يعني عندما
ياتي ياتي البرنامج الحكومي ويتحدث عن
قانون العفو على سبيل المثال لا معنى
لقانون العفو من دون معالجه المقدمات التي
تنتج اعتقالات عشوائيه و عشرات الالاف في
السجون من دون تهم او من دون احالتهم الى
القضاء عندما اتحدث عن قانون العفو من دون
اعاده هيكله المؤسسه القضائيه الفاسده
والمسي سه لا اهميه لمعالجه نتيجه هي
قانون العفو وهكذا يعني مع الاشياء الاخرى
انا اعتقد انه لم تلامس الى حد هذه اللحظه
الازمه الجوهريه في الع وهي ازمه النظام
السياسي الذي انتجه دستور عام 2005 طيب
استاذ عباس الموسوي اذا المشكله في العراق
لم تكن مشكله شخوص كما قال الدكتور يحي
الكبيسي لم تكون مشكله نوري المالكي لم
تكن مشكله رئاسه الحكومه ولكن كانت مشكله
ازمه نظام السياسي لم يكن متوازنا ماذا
تقول بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحياتي الك
ول الضيفين العزيزين والجمهور الكريم اتفق
معك المشكله في العراق هي
ليست مشكله كما ذكرت بالسيد المالكي او
غيره من السياسيين المشكله الطرف الاخر ما
زال يعيش ب عقده الحكم والسيطره والعوده
الى الحكم ما قدمه التحالف الوطني خلال
فتره تشكيل الحكومه ومن خلال ضغط السفير
الامريكي كان واضح على كل الكتل السياسيه
بتشكيل الحكومه التحالف الوطني قدم
تنازلات كبيره واحده من هذه التنازلات وهي
شروط كانت التي طرحها الطرف السني المشكله
المشكله انه الطرف السني غير متفق على
قياده واحده من يمثل الطرف السني في الع
العراق ومن يمثل مطالب السنه الان عندما
طبقت كل المطالب منها حصولهم على 40% من
من التشكيله الحكوميه الى الغاء مكتب
القائد العام الى تاسيس الحرس الوطني الى
الى الى ياتي طرف اخر ويقول نحن مهمشون
ونحن خارج السلطه المشكله بعض اخواننا مع
كل الاسف يعيشون عقده الماروني في لبنان
الماروني في لبنان عندما يخلق ويفتح عينه
يتصور سيكون رئيس جمهوريه بعض اخواننا من
الطرف الاخر يعيش عقده السلطه لذلك هو لا
يستطيع ان يرى انه انه عبد الزهره او فلان
او فلان هو جزء من التشكيله الحكوميه
الواقع العراقي الان نحن انا اقول التحالف
الوطني قدم الكث مسوي اسمح لي اقاطعك هنا
يعني انت تقول بان المشكله ليست في مشكله
شخوص وان مشكله الطرف الاخر الذي يريد ان
يعود الى الحكم او يحلم بالحكم مره اخرى
يعني اشراك المكون السني الذي تتعذر به
شخص صيات يعني تدافع عن
الحكومه لدى الطرف الاخر السني من يقول
بان ليس بالضروره ان تشرك افرادا في
الحكومه معناه ان المشاركه السياسيه
متوازنه لان لان هناك اشراك بدون اشراك في
القرار استاذ عبد الصمد نحن نعيش في اليه
ديمقراطيه ابناء المناطق السنيه انتخبوا
صالح المطلق واسامه النجيفي وغيرهم من
النواب وانا اقول هؤلاء لا يمثلون السنه
لانهم لا يستطيعون الذهاب الى محافظاتهم
وضربوا بالاحذيه في محافظاتهم ولكن هذه
نتيجه صناديق الانتخابات هذه اطيني طريقه
اليه لبناء الدوله غير صندوق الانتخابات
نذهب ونحل المشاكل من خلالها اريد اشرك
ايضا بيج كراولي معنا ما دمت تحدثت انت عن
نقطه ان المساله تمت بضغط من السفير
الامريكي في العراق وهنا اسال بجيك راولي
بجيك راولي يعني الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه طالما قالت في في الايام
الاخيره لنوري المالكي بان المشكله في
العراق مشكله سياسيه يقتضي حلها اشراك
الجميع لماذا شاركت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في هذه العمليه الان الاخيره
بتغيير المالكي بالعبادي وبارك هذا
التغيير دون ان يكون هناك تغيير جوهري
الذي تحدث عنه يحيى الكبيسي وهو اعاده
مراجعه العمليه السياسيه برمتها على اسس
متوازنه
هنا في الولايات المتحده لدينا مقوله تقول
ان كل متعلقات السياسه هي مقتضيات محليه
وايضا الاداء يعتمد على او التقييم يعتمد
على شيئين الاداء اولا ومن هذه الناحيه
المالكي لم يكن يؤدي بشكل فعال لم يكن
يوازن قواته الامنيه تخلت عن اراضي امام
الدوله الاسلاميه وال لدينا خبره في سنوات
مضت على هذه اذا من حيث الاداء فال
الحكومه العراقيه عليها ان تحسن من ادائها
على المستوى السياسي اضافه الى المستوى
الامني وهذا يؤدي الى مشكله التصورات او
كيف نتصور الواقع في العراق وخاصه في
المناطق التي غالبيتها سن هناك اناس
ينظرون الى تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه ثم
ينظرون الى الحكومه في بغداد فيعتبرون ان
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه هو اقل الضررين او
الشر الاهون ولكنهم لا يستطيعون تغيير مثل
هذا التصور لانه ان لم يتم تغيير هذا
التصور هذه الحكومه ستفشل كما سابق لكنج
كراولي بعد سقوط الموصل وانت تذكر جيدا
الامريكيون كانوا يتحدثون عن عن الحكم في
العراق وعن ازمه النظام السياسي في العراق
وعن طائفيه هذا الحكم الان هل التغيير
بالنسبه للامريكيين تغيير هذا هذا النظام
السياسي الغير متوازن او المختل هل يكون
بتغيير في الحكومه
فقط اعتقد ان هناك قضايا بنيويه هيكليه لم
يتم حلها داخل العراق حتى الان حكومه
العراقيه في بغداد لم تتوصل حتى الان الى
تفاهم كامل مع الاكراد ومع السنه كمكون في
البلاد حول ما هي المسؤوليات التي يجب ان
تولى للحكومه المركزيه في بغداد
واوله السلطات الى الاطراف والى الاقاليم
وكيف ي يتم اداره ذلك مثلا في المناطق
السنيه في المناطق الكرديه و و حت رغم ان
الحكومه موجوده منذ
2005 ما تزال هناك الكثير من التفاهمات
السياسيه
والاتفاقات التي لم يتم التوصل اليها فقط
في كثير من الامور ليس فقط فيما يخص
الحكومه المركزيه في بغداد بل في الاطراف
والمحافظات ايضا التي تستطيع ان تحكم
بطريقه تغير من تصورات وحسابات الشعب
العراقي في خطمه المطاف هكذا يكون الحاق
الهزيمه بظاهره الدوله الاسلاميه استاذ
يحي دكتور يحيى كبيسه يعني طرح قبل قليل
عباس الموسوي مساله مشاركه السنه في
العمليه السياسيه وان هناك ممثلين لهؤلاء
تم انتخابهم ولكنهم حينما يتوجهون الى
مناطقهم يتم قذفهم بالحجاره وطردهم
والسؤال هنا كيف للسنه ان يرضوا بعمليه
السياسيه كيف لهم ان يثقوا في سياسيه كيف
لهم ان يصلوا الى الى واقع ان هناك
سياسيين سنه يشاركون في العمليه السياسيه
واجن تهم تتطابق وتتناغم مع اجنده المشروع
السني السياسي
الشعبي يعني اعتقد هذا موضوع مهم اولا نحن
الان امام ازمه تمثيل سني عميقه يعني لا
احد من الموجودين في مجلس النواب او مجلس
الوزراء يستطيعون ان يدعون انهم يمثلون
المكون السني هذه حقيقه والاخطر انه معظم
هؤلاء السياسيين ان لم اقل 90% منهم غير
ليس لديهم اي تاثير حقيقي على الارض لكن
لنسال كيف وصل هؤلاء 70 من بال من من من
الممثلين السنه الموجودين اليوم في مجلس
النواب او في مجلس الوزراء هم وصلوا عبر
تحالفهم مع المالكي بمعنى المالكي هو الذي
دعاهم عبر التزوير عبر التاثير على
المفوضيه العليا المستقله للانتخابات وعبر
المال السياسي عندما يصل 70% من حلفاء
المالكي الى السلطه لدينا ازمه تمثيل سني
حقيقي يعني يعني حتى ساعطي مثل مهم المهم
انا اكرره دائما يعني السيد سليم الجبوري
رئيس مجلس النواب العراقي لولا تحالفه مع
المالكي لما استطاع ان يدخل الانتخابات
اصلا ولم استطاع ان يصل الى منصبه ولكن
كان هناك تحالف على ان يقبل هؤلاء حلفاء
المالكي بالمالكي لولايه ثالثه انتهت هذه
القضيه وبقينا مع ازمه التمثيل السني
العميقه هذا واحد اذا لدينا هذه المشكله
المشكله الثانيه التي يحاول ان يختصرها
ضيفك من بيروت بانه مشكله السنه لا لا في
العراق لدينا خلل ب في النظام السياسي هذا
النظام السياسي انتج بشراكه شيعيه كرديه
ولم يكن السنه طرفا فيه ولا وما لم يتم
اعاده صياغه هذ هذا النظام السياسي
بمشاركه فعليه من السنه لا حل للازمه في
العراق لنتفق جميعا على انه داعش في
العراق هو نتيج للمشكله السنيه في العراق
وما لم تحل المشكله السنيه في العراق لا
حل لداعش بمعنى حتى نظريا لو استطعنا
القضاء على داعش فانه التطرف سيبقى موجود
بسبب ممارسات السلطه القضيه الاخطر هنا
انه السلطه اليوم لم تعد حتى السلطه التي
كانت قائمه في ظل المالكي بمعنى كنا في ظل
المالكي نتحدث عن بنيه طائفيه للمؤسسه
العسكريه والمؤسسه الامنيه وعن بنيه
طائفيه للدوله الان اصبحت الميليشيات
المدعومه من ايران والتي على علاقه عضويه
من ايران جزء من هذا النظام بمعنى
الميليشيات الان هي التي حلت بديلا عن
الجيش وعن المؤسسات الامنيه عندما يتم
انتخاب شخص يتبع ميليشيا يعني انشئ في
ايران وقاتلت مع ايران ضد الجيش العراقي
في الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه لهذا المنصب
لدينا مشكله اساسيه انا اقول انه ليست
هناك اي مؤشرات على وجود اراده حقيقيه
لتغيير سياسي في العراق وعدم وجود هذه
الاراده السياسيه انا اعتقد يمنح يمنح
يعني هدايا مجانيه لداعش تستثمرها في
مناطقها بمعنى
نعم هذه النقطه بالذات دكتور يحي الكتور
يحيى هذه النقطه بالذات سنناقشها في الج
الجزء الثاني ه في الجزء الثاني سنناقش
هذه النقطه بالذات يعني اذا كان الامر
كذلك اذا كنتم لا ترون بان العمليه
السياسيه فعلا او هذا التغيير الحكومي
اعاد التوازن العمليه السياسيه سنسال مدى
قدره هذه الحكومه التي تم تشكيلها الان
على يعني التصدي للاولويه التي وضعت له
وهي محاربه تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه في
العراق سنناقش ذلك بعد هذا الفاصل فقوا
معنا مشاهدينا الكرام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدين الكرام من جديد في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش موضوع اكتمال تشكيل
الحكومه العراقيه وما الجديد فيها وقدرتها
على محاربه تنظيم الدوله نرحب بضيوفنا من
جديد استاذ عباس موسوي يعني سمعت ما قاله
الدكتور يحيى الكبيسي وهو اح يعني يطرح
سؤال مهم هذه الحكومه جاءت لتحارب تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه في العراق في العراق وهو
ضمن اولوياتها لكن السؤال كيف يمكن هذه
الحكومه ان تنجح في مهمتها وهي التي
ستخوضها يعني بجهد ناقص وهو غياب مكون سني
وهو جزء اصيل من الشعب
العراقي يعني هي بالتاكيد المسؤوليه
مسؤوليه المناطق السنيه المسؤوليه هي
المناطق السنيه مناطق عربيه وعشائر
بالتاكيد لا تقبل ان تنتهك ال هذه مسؤوليه
الدوله لا عندما تتعرض الدوله الى ازمات
بالتاكيد انا من حقي الشخصي ان ادافع عن
بيتي وعن منطقتي وعن عشيرتي اذا الدوله
مقصره في هذا الموضوع وتقصير الدوله له له
حساب اخر وله اذا اردنا ان نتكلم عنها
الاسباب التي ادت الى تقصير الدوله وعدم
تسليح الدوله وتحمل الولايات المتحده التي
الان جانت منقذه الى العراق هي تتحمل
الجزء الكبير في هذا الموضوع والصفقات
التي تمت ولكن من حيث الاساس لا يمكن ان
ابرر الى ابن الموصل ان يبقى يستسلم لدوله
داعش ويقول بحجه انها قويه وغير موجوده
ولكن لماذا شرعت المقاومه المقاومه التي
كانت في الجزائر وفي كل البلدان المحتله
الا اذا كانوا ينسجمون داخل لماذا لم
تقاوموا الاحتلال الامريكي حينما احتل
بغداد
فيقاوم نحن نحن من قاوم الاحتلال
الام في ام قصر لا لا لا خل نحن في ام قصر
لم تدخل القوات الامريكيه 20 يوم وتتذكر
وانما سلم
نحن نقول الوثائق ونحن ابناء الارض وكنا
على الارض ام قصر 20 يوم لم يدخلها
الامريكي الامريكي عندما اراد الانسحاب من
العراق وهو مذل طلب الامان من قوات من
قيادات المقاومه ان لا تضرب القيادات
الجيش الامريكي بالانسحاب وبعض المدن السن
لا اريد اقول سنيه ولكن بعض المدن الغربيه
سلمت مفاتيحها كامله الى القوا الامريكيه
هذا موضوع المقاومه موضوع موجود لذلك اعود
الى الان الموجود هذه المناطق الموصل
وصلاح الدين وغيرها عليها ان تقاوم الداعش
او هي منسجم معها اذا كانت منسجمه معها
علينا ان نفكر بطريقه اخرى اما اذا هي غير
منسجمه معها فعليها ان تق وهنالك بوادر
مقاومه لكن الحكومه لج الحكومه لجات الى
ميليشيات مسلحه شيعيه يتهمها الكثير من
السنه بانها كلما دخلت منطقه كان يسيطر
عليها تنظيم الدوله الا وعث فيها قتلا
وتعذيبه ت المليشيات التي تدعيها استاذ
عبدل دخلت الى الضلوعيه ودافعت عن ابناء
الضلوعيه وهي منطقه سنيه هنالك مناطق
دخلتها هذه المجموعات وهي ليست ميليشيات
وانما هي قوات الحشد الشعبي وابطال
المقاومه العراقيه لذلك
ماديه
ماذا فعلت في المقداديه وسلم بيك سليمان
بيك وين دخلت وحررت المناطق واستجابه
واستنجاد من اهلها لذلك تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه ماذا فعل في بغداد من يدافع عن
ظهم يا موسوي عباس انا لا اتهم وانما هذا
هناك تقرير صدر عن منظمه العفو الدوليه
قبل اسبوع يتهم فيه ميليشيا طائفيه كما
قال تقريب ارتكاب جرائم ضد الانسانيه ضد
السنه العراقيين وقال جرى ذلك بتغطيه ومف
ق من الحكومه العراقيه والحكومه نفسها
قامت بعملي تعذب ضد مواطنين السنه دعني
هنا انتقل حتى اشرك بيجي كراولي بيجي
كراولي اسمحي ساعود اليك بيجي كراولي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ايضا ينظر
اليها يعني بشكل يعني انها تقوم او تنفذ
سياسه غير متوازنه في العراق كانت تشاهد
وتتابع ما يجري من ظلم في حق المكون السني
في عهد نوري المالكي ولم تتحرك على ارض
الميدان لكنها الان تدخلت يقول البعض ل
بدافع حمايه الاقليات ضد الايزيديين وايضا
لحمايه الاكراد بشكل فعلي بعمل عسكري في
العراق اليس هذا كيل
بمكيالين اقول اولا ان الولايات المتحده
اعادت انخراطها العسكري في العراق بناء
على دعوه من حكومه بغداد
لم يكن الامر كذلك ما كان الولايات
المتحده ان تفعل ما تفعله الان ولكن
السؤال الحقيق وهل ما تفعله في سوريا
بدعوه من الحكومه السوريه اسمحلي اسمحلي
هذا الامر مردود عليه هل ما تفعله في
سوريا هو بدعوه من النظام
السوري سوريا لها حساب
مختلفه كثيرا فهناك نوع من التفاهم مع
حكومه الاسد لكن الولات المتحده ليست
متحالفه مع حكومه الاسد اما سياق العراق
هو كالاتي هل بالامكان
اعاده التفاهم
والاتفاق المشترك الذي كان موجودا في 2006
و27 عندما كان السنه في المناطق السنيه
وتوحد قضيتهم مع الحكومه الامريكيه
والحكومه العراقيه في بغداد لالحاق
الهزيمه بالقاعده هذه الديناميكيه التي
يجب ان نخلقها وهي الفرصه التي اضاعتها
حكومه المالكي بعد رحيل الامريكان في
العام 2011 هذه الديناميكيه التي يجب ان
تعاد والسؤال هو هل من بماذا نقوم اولا هل
نعزز الامن اولا ثم نشيع الثقه في النظ
السياسي ام العكس هذا ما على حكومه
العبادي ان تفعله ان تجد لاعبين اساسيين
في المناطق السنيه يتعاونون معها لاستعاده
الاراضي من تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه بدعم
من قوات الامن العراقيه التي ينظر اليها
وكانها تقاتل تنظيم الدوله ولا تقاتل
الشعب الع يحي الكبيسي انتم الان بين
مطرقه يعني تهميش الحكومه العراقيه كما
تقولون وبين سندان وقوع في ارض المعركه
التي تخوضها الحكومه والتحالف الدولي ضد
تنظيم الدوله كيف لكم ان تنخرط في هذا
العمل المطلوب منكم وهو محاربه كما قال
كما قال عباس الموسوي محاربه تنظيم الدوله
وانتم تقولون لان الحكومه لم تعطيكم
حقوقكم كامله
باختصار هنا هناك ثلاثه اشياء اولا هناك
انعدام مطلق بالسلطه في بغداد هناك انعدام
سني مطلق السلطه في بغداد هناك انعدام ثقه
مطلق بالمؤسسه العسكريه والامنيه هناك رفض
مطلق للميليشيات التي يسميها ضيفك الحشد
الشعبي هذه الميليشيات هي ليست اقل خطرا
من داعش والجمهور السني ينظر على اليها
على انها اكثر خطرا من داعش كيف نحل هذه
المشكلات الثلاثه ونستعيد ثقه المواطن
السني ببغداد هذا يحتاج اولا اعاده هيكله
لنظام السياسي اعاده هيكله للقوات
العسكريه والامنيه العراقيه مح يعني
معاقبه هذه الميليشيات ومحاسبتها على انها
مليشيات ارهابيه ترتكب جرائم ضد الانسانيه
وجرائم حرب شكرا لك يحي الكبيسي مستشار
المركز العراقي للدراسات استراتيجيه من
عمان نشكر ايضا من بيروت عباس موسوي مدير
المركز الاعلامي العراقي في بيروت و
واشنطن بيجي كراولي المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه سابقا شكرا لكم والى
اللقاء بحول
الله
[موسيقى]
ا